it looks like the uh braves are loose
and ready to go
we're doing things texas style the home
of the texas rangers in arlington
and walker bueller is ready to go
freddy freeman who
had a career year in many respects
albeit with a 60-game schedule hits one
into right and this one is gone
freddie freeman
shoots one out to right
his family's excited his dugouts excited
and the braves
strength first in the nlcs two on with
two out a hit and walk here's the o2
got him swinging laid on a fastball
and max freed comes away with three
strikeouts in the bottom of the first
inning
played totally different indeed
two days ago
as opposed to yesterday when the roof
was open that's a pop-up
that is muncie and not enough room
and
duvall may have injured himself on that
swing let's watch
oh you don't like to see that that's uh
that's an important part of any
position out on the field especially
hitting or pitching the wall's going to
come out so the rbi opportunity for
riley
is at second base two balls to strikes
two out bueller delivers swung on and
missed strike three change up and that
ends the inning so that's the change
with duvall coming out of the ball game
here's the 1-1
crack to ozzy a diving stop on the
outfield grass pops up throws to first
base and they get bellinger that's a gem
of a play at second base by ozzy albies
two out and what max freed would give
for a one two three third inning
a strikeout and it is the first one two
three inning five walks now by bueller
two on one out and marcake is coming up
right down the middle struck him out and
strikeout number six
for walker bueller two out in the unit
that'll bring in austin reilly
hits one in the air to center got under
it a bit
bellinger
ends the inning first up [ __ ] hernandez
for the dodgers down by a run
that's called making your first start of
this postseason count with a blast
by the dodgers second baseman
well that's what he can do he got a
hanging breaking ball and now his
seventh
postseason home run
a big
[Music]
[Applause]
tie ball game two on one out now a pitch
man
two out in the inning as pache goes down
this kid a former
minnesota twin pitcher they may have
their future closer right here
back to him makes the play
how about the kid underhands to first he
comes in and gets the job done on six
pitches
no runs two hits two left
that is into left center field and ball
is down into the wall
ozuna with
a double
to start this eighth inning off may
keep talking about ozuna a magical year
3-2 pitch
struck him out on a pitch down and in
two out
the bases are loaded now
charlie culberson
off the bench
batting for nick marcakis who was over
three
no balls two strikes two out bases low
to the pitch culverson strikes out
swinging on a slider that ends the
inning and gonzales
comes in and gets the job done this has
been a classic game you can't get more
even one run four hits for each team the
3-2 got him swinging strike three
and a one two three inning for smith and
the braves bull pin flexes against the
dodger match in the bottom of the eighth
inning in a 1-1 ball game here in the
ninth to austin reilly
that has hit deep into left center field
back at the wall it's gone
austin riley
has put the atlanta braves on top here
in the ninth with a home run off blake
trining
absolute
laser
that was a blast in the left center
field and now it'll be upon
ozuna
try and get the runner in at third with
less than two out three two
little fly ball into right base it
and it's three to one atlanta on top
ozuna his second straight hit
nothing into the count
that is well hit
[Music]
we've been talking about strength versus
strength both teams hitting the home run
ball but it's the braves who flex harder
tonight as they have hit now three home
runs in the ball game here's cody
ballinger two out nobody on 5-1 atlanta
here in game one another 0-2 back to
melanson over him to the shortstop
swanson graves take game one
a final of five to one